- Alright guys, what's up?
How's it goin'?
Hey, what's up?
Hello, hello, alright anyway,
let's get on with the video.
I really wanna get more
Instagram followers
so why don't you guys follow me?
That's the whole video.
It's just a little vlog of me
asking you guys to follow me.
No, for real, I really wanna
get more Instagram followers.
Right now I have about
8,000 on my Instagram page
Which may seem like a lot
but compared to other
social media people who have
millions and millions and
millions and millions and millions
of followers, it really isn't that much.
So I've been doing some research
and it seems like what's really popular
on Instagram right now is body painting.
Which is basically just female models
getting painted in clothes and
it looks like they're dressed
but they're actually naked.
So all I have to do is get one
of these accounts to
use me as their model.
I spent the next few
hours trying to contact
every single body painting
Instagram page I could find.
Guys, Jen the Body Painter,
who get millions and millions of views
on each one of her posts just
agreed to use me as her model.
I am super excited to do this.
I hope I get a bunch of
followers out of this.
Let's go.
Hey, how's it goin'?
- Good, good, good.
Is there anything I can
do to prepare for this?
- Wax the whole body?
Do it for the Instagram followers.
So I'm heading downtown
to get a sugar wax.
Sugaring's supposed to hurt a
lot less than regular waxing.
It's just lemon, water,
and what the (bleep)
was the last ingredient?
- Oh sugar, there we go.
(laughing)
So it's not hot, you're
not gonna get burnt,
and they pull in the direction
that your hair grows.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I got to the salon and
I was really nervous.
So was the lady.
I had a lot of chest hair and I asked her
if maybe I could have a local
anesthetic or something.
She gave me some baby powder.
(groaning)
Oh, man.
(heavy metal music)
(screaming)
Hurt so bad I ended up passing out.
When I woke up and looked down I realized
I have a 13-year-old Bar Mitzvah bod.
I took my hairless bod to go
buy some very little underwear
because I can't be naked in the shoot.
I met Jen the Body Painter
and her whole family
but before we started shooting,
I wanted to learn a little bit
about how they got into this.
It stemmed from like using
bodies to advertise things?
- Pretty much 'cause when I got painted
as a cheetah I got so much attention.
- Is it very different
than regular painting?
- Oh yeah because the person moves.
So with like a canvas, you just
can just sit there for hours
and play your music whatever,
feel really relaxed.
- So how long does it take usually?
- Captain America was
seven to eight hours.
For you, right now what
we're getting ready to do
it's gonna take us two and a half hours.
- So you guys are like
a family who just...
- Does really weird things together.
So I would literally come home from school
and as soon as I'd walk in the door,
like our kitchen is in sight,
so I would see like topless
girls just walking around.
- My mom never painted
naked models in my house.
It was just like my dad
walking around naked.
Anyway, time for me to get naked.
It was awkward because
I realized I'm at work.
- What the (bleep) is happening right now?
(laughing)
We then had to take a bunch
of pictures for the thumbnail.
Being an instagrammer isn't easy.
Then they gave me so pre-painted shorts,
so they didn't have to paint my, you know.
Looked at their phone to
find pictures of clothes
and started painting.
(electronic music)
She also had to paint
inside my belly button.
That was a big no-no.
(electronic music)
Time for the big reveal.
Oh dude! Holy (bleep)!
Wow!
Oh my god.
Yo, it looks so good!
Wow!
If anybody watches Friends,
when Bruce Willis talks
to himself and he's like
"Who's a sex machine?"
I'm a sex machine right now.
I said that and nobody laughed
so it made me uncomfortable.
(laughing)
This painting is insane.
You did that on me while I
was like talking and laughing?
- [Jen] Yeah.
- How's my butt look?
- [Jen] Great.
- [Second artist] Amazing
- [Jen] Never looked better.
- It's time to go out,
see if people notice,
see what people think.
BuzzFeed, get ready for Naked Eric.
(acapella singing)
At first people didn't even notice.
And when they did, they
didn't know what it was.
- Are those leggings?
- [Eric] Yeah!
- Are they even pants or
are they just leggings?
- That feels like your skin.
Is it your skin?
- [Eric] It's my skin.
- Wait. What the (bleep)?
- Oh wait. Oh my god it's paint.
(laughing)
- This is...
- I'm naked.
(laughs)
- It looked like a real shirt.
I'm like that is a small, tiny shirt.
Oh my god.
(laughs)
- Are you a little cold?
It's a bit nipplely in here.
- You're wearing underwear because...
- No, no, no.
My penis is taped to my leg.
(laughing)
No, no, no, I'm kidding.
It's not, I'm wearing underwear.
- Oh thank god, thank god.
- How would it be taped?
To what?
- It's also blizzarding outside
so maybe not the wisest
choice today but...
- Not at all, I have to go outside
- I cannot stop staring at your penis.
I am so sorry Eric, I just can't do it.
- Look at my eyes, that's who I am.
- Now you know how I feel all the time.
- So this was super fun.
Most people had no idea.
It took a lot of people
a long time to realize
I was painted and once
they realized, they were
so impressed with the paint job.
So I think that's the coolest
thing about this video
was like how good these
guys are at what they do.
Body painting truly is an art
form, it's really impressive.
Now I'm gonna head home, figure
out how to wash this off.
Getting home sucked because
there was a blizzard outside
and well, paint doesn't
really keep you warm.
(heavy metal music)
My nipples are so hard right now.
Showering was fun though, I
looked like a human bath bomb.
It looked pretty cool.
I've been in the shower for 45 minutes,
and it's still not coming off.
And my whole shower is bleached black.
So I just finished
editing, it's been a week.
And here's the update: Jen
the body painter has posted
my post, she tagged me in it.
It currently has over 500,000 views.
And my Instagram page
(drum roll)
I only got 100 followers.
I waxed my whole body for 100 followers.
I've been itchy all
week for 100 followers.
Everyone just cared
about the body painters,
and not about me.
I'm not giving up, though.
I'm gonna keep making these videos
till I get a million followers.
(soft jazz music)